في العاصمه الاوكرانيه حتى هو وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
رحله حاملا دعما معنويا واخرا ماليا يفوق
المليار دولار
والهدف ضمان تفوق العسكري الاوكراني على
المدى الطويل مع استمرار هجومك في المضاد
كيف تلقفت الدعم بالتنديد بالهجمات
الروسيه على مواليها وما قالت انه استهداف
متعمد للمدنيين اما موسكو فشددت على ان
الدعم واشنطن لن يغير مساره ولا نتيجه ما
تسميه عملياتها العسكريه الخاصه وفي
التفاصيل قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
كارينا
ان زياره وزير الخارجيه اوكرانيا والاعلان
عن حزمه مساعدات امنيه جديده هي رساله
امريكيه واضافه انها حزمه المساعدات
الجديده لاوكرانيا تتضمن المزيد من ذخيره
المدفعيه وانظمه مضاده للدروع
واشددت على ان الهجمات الروسيه تؤكد اهميه
الاستمرار في دعم اوكرانيا في مواجهه
العدوان الروسي
هذا وكانت اثره دفاع الامريكيه اعلنت عن
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه بقيمه
175 مليون دولار تتضمن ضخائر اليورانيوم
المنظم لدبابات كما تشمل الحزمه الجديده
عتادا لدعم انظمه الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيه
وهذا خائرا لراجمات هاي مارس وقذائف
مدفعيه وصواريخ مضاده للدروع ونقل مراسل
جزيره فينتاجون عن مسؤول دفاعي الامريكي
قوله انه تم اتخاذ القرار بتزويد اوكرانيا
بذخيره اليورانيوم المنظم الان كي تكون
جاهزه للاستخدام متى تسلمت كييف دبابات
وهو امر متوقع في الخريف المقبل لكن
الموعد النهائي لم يحدد بعد